moving on to federal health officials
boosting supply of the monkey pox
vaccine because of a surge in new cases
they're up more than 30 percent in the
last week alone and our tiny rivera is
here with the latest to control this
worsening outbreak tiny good morning the
numbers going in the wrong direction
they certainly are good morning tony
there are now more than 14 000 cases of
monkey pox in the u.s and while the
government is vowing to ramp up vaccine
supply many people at highest risk say
they're still having a hard time finding
appointments
there weren't any appointments available
and so i found that pretty frustrating
and maybe a little scary after waiting
about a month twenty-year-old edward
o'keefe finally received his first dose
of the monkey pox vaccine at this new
jersey clinic thursday frankly like the
government has dropped the ball to meet
the growing rise in cases amidst a
shortage of vaccines the cdc is now
encouraging one-fifth of the dose be
administered just below the skin arguing
that will stretch supply
the white house says it will distribute
almost 2 million doses to regions that
adopt that change cdc director dr
richelle wilinski admits there's still a
lot the government has to learn about
this outbreak including the
effectiveness of the vaccines we expect
protection to be the highest two weeks
after the second dose of the vaccine
according to the cdc 98 percent of
monkey pox cases are in men 93 percent
among men who reported recent sexual
contact with other men
and more than 60 percent of cases are
among men of color we're not reaching
men who have sex with men who are black
and brown the way that we need to and
now the numbers of infected children
have started to rise there are at least
12 confirmed cases of children with
monkey pox in the u.s children are at
higher risk for severe monkey pox it can
even be deadly and very young children
dr gallander says the most likely source
of exposure to monkey pox for children
is through close contact with a
caregiver
the government will also set aside an
extra 50 000 vaccine doses available for
cities with large gay pride events
coming up but it is important to
remember even though most cases are in
men who have sex with other men anyone
can get this virus tony get it the
numbers are moving in the wrong
direction yeah anybody can get it but
how difficult is it tanya to get is
there a way to explain it is difficult
you shouldn't be overly concerned but it
can spread through infected bedding
infected towels infected clothes so just
take precautions so it's not necessarily
just skin-to-skin when you're talking
about bedding right don't share towels
in the locker room for instance all
right vlad mine's got my name on it
thank you very much